homemade pasta is honestly like next
level don't be intimidated don't be
afraid it's easier than you think
honestly this is one of those things
that you've just got to try
[Music]
the only ingredients you need to make
pasta from scratch are flour salt eggs
and extra virgin olive oil the first big
question with homemade pasta is what
type of flour should i use and you know
it's pretty debated there's tons of
recipes with all purpose a bunch of
double o a bunch of semolina most often
times you'll see like half and half if
you prefer that more like al dente bite
that's going to be more what you want to
do with like a half semolina half all
purpose we found that it was a little
bit harder to work with when you're
rolling it out by hand a really
traditional route is to use the double o
flower which is what we're going to do
here it's just very finely ground and
testing this one had the best texture
for us it was really nice working with
it as well it gave us like a really
smooth silky dough and so for that we do
recommend splurging for it that being
said it can be a little bit hard to find
so you know all purpose is something
that you have in your pantry at all
times pretty much the all-purpose also
gives you like a great texture it's
still going to give you an awesome
result and so with that said we actually
ended up with two ultimate recipes so
whether you choose double o flour or
stick to all-purpose you'll get a great
result so let's get started we made this
recipe to be accessible to everyone so
this is specifically made for people who
are rolling their dough out by hand so
it's a little bit softer it's a little
more enriched and it's got all these
great pantry essentials that everyone
has and it's a really really great
beginner's look into making your own
pasta
you can still make really delicious
pasta with all-purpose or plain flour to
start off you just need two cups of that
with a good pinch of salt two eggs six
egg yolks i learned this trick at a
restaurant and what's great about this
is you can crack a whole bunch of eggs
and you can get it done a lot quicker
than you know really gingerly trying to
go back and forth between the two shells
and here you just do a little shake and
the white just comes out between your
fingers and it's just a really quick
easy way and lastly just a tablespoon or
so of extra virgin olive oil the oil is
optional but especially if you're
rolling this out by hand it makes the
dough a little bit softer and a lot
easier to roll out so that's why we're
using it in this recipe so if you're
going to spring for the more traditional
double o flour what you're going to get
as a result is a very soft silky texture
to your pasta and for this one we're
going to use three eggs and five yolks
whereas for the all-purpose we needed
more of that fat to help limit the
gluten development and to make the
all-purpose dough easier to work with
overall all right so now it's time to
make a mess you're going to dump your
flour out on the board and using your
hands you're going to make a large well
in the middle and that well is going to
hold our eggs when we slowly incorporate
them into the dough and after doing this
a few times and having the eggs fall
everywhere trust us make the well bigger
than you think it needs to be so
incorporate the oil into the eggs and
beat them a little bit you don't want to
incorporate any air or anything you just
kind of want to break up the eggs and
the yolks you're going to carefully pour
that into the well and then slowly whisk
the eggs what that's going to do is pull
a little bit of flour more and more into
your dough and what that's going to do
is prevent any large chunks from forming
in the dough you're gonna use your fork
to slowly grab a little bit more of the
flour and slowly incorporate the flour
into the eggs to gradually thicken the
eggs and eventually make it into a dough
but worst case scenario if you have a
breech and the egg starts going
everywhere i think the biggest thing
here is just don't panic because you
still do kind of want to slowly
incorporate the flour into the dough you
don't want to just douse it all in there
all at once once you have almost all the
flour incorporated and you're confident
that it's all turning into like a much
thicker mixture you can clean off your
fork and just start going in with your
hands and kneading the dough together
what we're looking for is a nice
malleable dough but not something that's
so sticky that it's covering your hands
in the dough you buy eggs some are
larger than others so if your eggs are
really large and you're feeling like
your dough is really wet and sticky
that's a really easy fix you just add a
little bit more flour if your dough is
really dry like if you're using pretty
small eggs the best thing to do is break
up another egg with a splash of water so
it's kind of thin and then using your
hand to kind of sprinkle that egg
mixture on you want to make sure that
you're just kind of as evenly as you can
getting moisture into the dough and then
kneading that in the biggest mistake
when people are making doughs is just
not needing it enough and this is
honestly going to take a good seven to
ten minutes like set a timer for
yourself to make sure that you're doing
it long enough and this is just to
develop the gluten and also make sure
that you have a very smooth well
incorporated dough and there's a few
different ways to do it what you're
trying to do is get the outside dough
incorporated in the center part of the
dough so what i'm doing is kind of
lifting and then rolling the dough back
on itself so this way i'm kind of
getting all parts of the dough and
evenly working it all into itself you
want to be gentle enough that you're not
tearing the dough what you're doing is
just
folding and rolling there's also another
way to do this and i call this the hard
method because you kind of end up making
a bit of a heart shape on your board
when you're done it's the same idea
you're just rolling and folding but
either way it's kind of the same process
of incorporating the outside of the
dough with the inside of the dough it's
more so just finding a way that works
for you and is comfortable for you to be
doing so for five to ten minutes unless
you have a tag team for people to help
you and a good signal to know when your
pasta dough is done is by poking it and
what you're looking for here is this
kind of spring back you want to see that
the dough comes back at you when you
poke it so you're seeing that kind of
stretchy quality the gluten is
developing and once we're happy that
we've kneaded for long enough we're
going to cover it with cling film and
leave it out at room temperature for 30
minutes to an hour what that's going to
do is allow the gluten to rest a little
bit so that when it's time to roll out
it's not going to spring back at you
at this point the dough is going to be
much softer much more relaxed so it's
going to be much easier to roll out now
that we let it rest so we're going to
unwrap our dough and then we're going to
break it up into pieces to make it again
easier to work with and we're going to
put the others to the side covering them
with cling film so they don't dry out
while we roll out our first piece so
we're going to make a thick linguine and
so we want to roll it out into one long
piece so when you're rolling out pasta
dough it'll start kind of making a
really oblong shape so a way that you
can avoid doing that is once you're
rolling it out in this long shape you
can fold the top third down and then the
bottom third over that so you're kind of
folding it like a letter almost and then
again continue rolling back and forth
back and forth it'll help result in a
much more even rectangle and be a little
bit easier to roll out in an even shape
so there's no waste and it's also going
to help soften the dough a little bit
make it just that much easier on
yourself you want to roll this out
thinner than you think even the old
saying about pasta dough is you want to
be able to read a love letter through it
but the point is you want to be able to
see your hand through the dough the
reason why you wanted to be so thin is
when you put it in the boiling water
it's automatically going to swell a
little bit because it is taking on some
water so if it's not thin enough now
you're going to end up with a really
thick pasta depending on how exact you
want your noodles to look you can cut
off some of the edges but don't go to
crazy lengths trying to get perfectly
shaped pasta this is handmade it's
rustic you know it's never going to be
as perfect as a machine but that's kind
of the point so an easy way to make sure
that you're getting good cuts here is to
roll it up in kind of a large loose roll
you want the layers to be dry enough
that they're not going to stick to each
other and so that way when you cut them
they don't just form into one massive
blob and then you can just make simple
cuts depending on the width you want
your pasta it's much easier to cut it
this way instead of doing long straight
lines then you want to immediately kind
of fluff out those rolls and put them
into their individual strands and put
them aside while you make some more and
you can totally cut these to your
preference you can do thinner than this
you can do thicker for pepperdill just
think about what kind of sauce you're
going to be serving them with or kind of
the way that you like your noodles and
if you want to make the cutest pasta
ever you can cut them into little bow
ties and stick to the same thing you
want to do the roll you want to cut long
strips and then you want to cut those
strips into little rectangles and then
all you need to do is take your index
finger and thumb and pinch them in the
middle and make the cutest little bow
ties around this one's a little more
time consuming so we wouldn't recommend
doing this unless you have a bunch of
friends helping you as well
but they're so cute that it's worth it
there's literally a million ways to cut
pasta so just have fun with it you know
you've done all the hard work now it's
kind of the fun part of shaping it also
like don't go too crazy it's rustic it's
handmade it's going to be beautiful it's
going to taste great while you're making
all of your shapes you want to make sure
that you have some extra flour on hand
to dust over the finished cut pasta it's
going to prevent the pasta from sticking
to itself but it's also going to
slightly dry it out a little bit that's
going to give your final pasta a nice
toothy texture so this pasta is fresh
therefore it's not going to take nearly
as long to cook as dried pasta would you
really just need a few minutes in some
salted boiling water and you want to
kind of break up the pasta before you
put it in and then you know give it a
nice stir once it's in the water as well
just like with dried pasta we want to
make sure that it's not sticking and
moving it around in the boiling water is
going to help prevent that the only way
to know when the pasta's done is to
taste it so after you know two or three
minutes in the boiling water give it a
taste see if it's done to your liking
and as always save a cup or so of the
pasta water to help finish off your
sauce later so once you have your
strained pasta you're gonna add it to
your sauce a little bit of pasta water
and cheese if you like here we use brown
butter and sage and a bit of parmesan
this is honestly a great method you're
going to get great pasta hand rolling it
but if you do this quite often or this
is something you really get into it's
honestly worth the investment getting a
pasta roller it's going to be a little
bit easier it's going to give you a
little bit more of an even result but
don't feel like the first time you're
making pasta you have to invest in this
20 30 machine honestly the satisfaction
and
the beautiful result of fresh pasta is
pretty special it doesn't have to be
perfect it's a few simple ingredients
it's
pretty much one of the best things on
the planet there are a few things better
than a warm bowl of pasta so
give it a go
try it on the weekend and list your
friends make a party out of it and you
can't go wrong with a bowl of fresh
pasta look how beautiful that is look at
that pasta it's pretty great i'm sad
we're not eating it right now because we
already ate
god my husband's lucky to be with you
yeah
i really want more pasta now i know i'm
really hungry look at the brown butter
bits on that pasta
[Music]